you
good morning my name is Alan Timberlake
it is my honor to serve as a host of
this event on behalf of Columbia's world
leaders forum I'm here as director of
the East Central European Center a
center which studies the geographical
arc of states on the western edge at the
former Soviet Union from Bulgaria to
Estonia and therefore includes Albania
it's gratifying to see several of these
states represented by the highest
officials here at Columbia in the world
leaders forum earlier this week the
presidents of Estonian and selenium and
today it is our honor to have Prime
Minister Eddie Rama of Albania his
presence here is evidence of the new
vitality and visibility of these states
in today's world and we are honored to
have the Prime Minister as our guest
today to introduce our guests formally I
would like to call on David L Phillips
mr. Phillips has an impressive record of
service and activity in various roles in
multiple domains of public life in
government as foreign affairs expert and
senior adviser to the Department of
State second as fellow or teacher in
academic institutions third work in
policy think-tanks fourth in human
rights organizations and fifth in
communication as an analyst for news
outlets and as an author of numerous
papers and several significant books
notably his recent book liberating
Kosovo course of diplomacy and US
intervention closer to home and closer
to the present moment David Phillips is
now director the problem on peace
building and rights within the Institute
for the study of human rights here in
Columbia mr. Phillips
thank you very much Alan Fallon's Irish
um a warm welcome to prime minister
Eddie Rama your visit here comes at a
wonderful moment for Albania
because Albania is really surging as a
country in recent years it's gained NATO
membership its acquired EU visa
liberalisation Brussels has provided a
twelve-step plan for its candidacy we've
also seen Albania play a very
constructive role as Kosova has gained
its independence Albania is now covered
with infrastructure with roads and
utilities and it's whether the financial
storms of Europe so this surge is also
met by very high expectations during the
recent campaign mr. Rama made some
important pledges to the Albanian people
to eliminate the flat tax in the v80 to
decrease taxes on small and medium-sized
business to create a hundred three
hundred thousand new private-sector jobs
free healthcare subsidized food and fuel
the Albanian people clearly now are
looking to Prime Minister Rama to
provide the kind of guidance and
leadership that will bring Albania
closer to Europe and fully integrate
Albania into euro-atlantic institutions
so the mantle of responsibility now
rests with you you're very well suited
for this great task being an artist an
athlete as well as a political actor you
served as the mayor of Tirana beginning
in 2003 for many years since 2005 mr.
Rama has chaired the Socialist Party of
Albania he led it to an overwhelming
victory just recently On June 23 and
just stays prior to coming to the United
States the government transition was
completed
and mr. Rama is now fully installed as
Albania's new Prime Minister so it's
with high hopes that you are welcome to
that office and very warmly welcomed
here to Columbia University thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much for inviting me and
thank you for finding the time all of
you to come and listen to me in one of
the very first exercises of speaking to
an audience as Prime Minister which is
not an easy exercise because I'm used to
speak since many years as leader of the
Opposition so it's quite a change of
language but anyway I'll try and I hope
that you'll not get bored because I
think one of the things that change from
opposition to government is the
increased risk to be boring it was 1990
when in Albania first important blow was
given to the communist dictatorship mass
movement and student movement had pushed
the single parts leadership to accept
the existence of other parties Albania
had been a pluralistic political system
people could be represented by political
forces other than the Communist Party
that had ruled with an iron fist since
1945 it was symbolically the end of the
dictatorship easier said than done we
won't have been able be like Europe was
back then the slogan of thousands in
streets young and old
women and men people who in their lives
had never traveled outside the country
everybody wanted Albania to become like
Europe this slogan did not represent
simply a dream or an aspiration it stood
as a firm belief in the capacities of
the country it stood as a claim of
identity it stood as a demand to return
to the path from which generations were
forcefully derailed it stood as a clear
statement of the will of the people
since then all the political parties in
the country have been proclaiming
integration to the European Community at
then the European Union as their main
aspiration and the main aim of their
political and government programs quite
wise and legitimizing in terms of
representation though easier said than
done
it was 1990 when the eurovision song
contest was won by otto cotugno with his
song in siena 1992 or otherwise known in
cma unite unite Europe 1992 the song was
gleamed in the voices of thousands
referred to a common European flag
citizens beyond frontiers and a common
European dream petunia was accompanied
by a Slovenian group in his performance
in Eurovision when they sang Europe is
not far away he's not a dream anymore
let's come together and unite unite
Europe beautifully said though easier
said than done the titles of song
pointed out to a year 1992 the year when
the European Union was set to begin
functioning as such the year of the
master eight agreements through which
the European community became the
European Union and set the foundations
for an effective and active union
through the objectives of democrat of
democratizing the new institutions the
developing common foreign and security
policy establishing police and judicial
cooperation in criminal matters
otherwise through establishing the main
pillars of European Union that same year
a new year was also open in Albania with
a March 1992 elections when finally
after more than 40 years of
totalitarianism a political party came
to power through people's free votes
representing their aspirations and will
as the song inspiringly proclaimed we
thought we had found each other in
Europe we thought we'd finally found
Europe in Albania though there was a
long way to go for United Europe to
enact his unity in terms of a common
European identity that would supersedes
national identities in terms of European
institutions that would have a firm say
over national institutions in terms of
well-functioning european common market
including an European single currency
that was not perpetually threatened to
be thrown away each time the European
governments experiences economic
difficulties but most certainly there
was a long way to go for Albania in
terms of building democratic state
institutions civil society a justice
system independent from politics a State
Administration immune from corruption
and simply a process of free and fair
elections the difficulties in regulating
a national market that up to that moment
had been totally isolated from foreign
investments and totally dominated by
state monopolies were immense
because immense was also the appetite of
politicians that finally an individual
grasp on national resources but also in
mass was immense was a desire of
individuals to catch up with the
opportunities denied in long years more
ever
moreover the educational system had long
before the early nineties failed in
responding to the necessities of a world
developing in scientific research and
technology like never before so the
country that thought to have finally
rejoined Europe was faced to limited
knowledge to build democratic
institutions similar to those in
developed in developed European
countries a chaotic market economy and
in existence civil society and a state
structure incapable to respond to new
challenges and to that belief no matter
how subjective it was we want Albania to
be like Europe on the other hand Europe
that finally had a union was going to be
faced with challenges that even today
put the Union into question as they are
fundamental challenges related to the
quality of democracy you will find the
debates of French intellectuals
activists social scientists on the
frontiers of democracy quite revelatory
in that matter
the nature and the meaning of European
citizenship the debates of citizenship
Beyond Borders active citizenship
bottom-up decision-making acts of
citizenship of intellectuals and
researchers particularly in UK are very
clarifying in this aspect the viability
of European single currency in this case
you will find national debates about the
pros and cons of the euro and
particularly analysis of Greek crisis
very interesting and useful nevertheless
the challenges Albania had to face were
more critical and Albania was soliciting
membership to European Union European
Union has been since then a key
incentive for democratization and
modernization Brussels became guidance
with democratization and modernization
in the country however the relationship
has been one of Brussels as a mentor
putting forward homework assignments and
Albania but also other Balkan countries
spoiled students that never finish their
homework as they should after long years
of such mentorship we know Vania had a
legislative framework pretty much
responding brussels demands but we had a
reality radically different from what
brussels expected actually a thing that
we did a homework in a very creative way
submitting to brussels a lot of very
well filled papers like hanging
beautiful curtains that hid behind a
totally different reality for that much
brussels has seen from interior side of
these windows and from that much
legislation and various common project
you have affected the everyday reality
in the country Albania is the potential
candidate that has signed the
stabilisation and Association agreement
and expects the candidate status in
December this year after long years of
transition from a totalitarian regime to
democracy that is called functioning
democracy although it has not really
been functioning and after long years of
nourishing and imaginary a new imaginary
of Europe we know that we want Albania
to be like Europe otherwise the problem
nation of the will to integration the
European Union should not be a
propagandistic lightening teeth but
totally other tality of concrete state
reforms toward modernization and
democratization it should not be a
process of producing very correctly
filled papers or thousands of meetings
between bureaucrats but the system of
values and institutions we discuss
largely and implement targeting the
quality of people's life and future
generations in early 90s
Albania said we want Albania to be like
Europe but politicians afraid of taking
responsibility started to talk about our
journey towards the European Union the
metaphor of the Train was used Albania a
train that was moving fast towards
Europe and there's a leader of a
position I was also sometimes accused of
not being in that
train but which one the one full of
papers the one that was moving the rails
of governmental propaganda yes I am NOT
in that one because Europe is not a
destination beside us beyond us external
to us it is a destination within us it
is a daily democracy in our country it
represents the awareness that our
day-to-day actions as decision-makers
affect the life and opportunities of
people today and generations of tomorrow
the next generations of Europe key to
the new agenda approach to you
enlargement in the southeast Europe
should be this awareness that the common
future of the next generation of Europe
is building member countries as much as
in candidate countries as much as in
potential candidates which means in
Southeast Europe thus the question
should not be how to make South East
Europe ready for the European Union
but how we all together you can build
the united Europe how we all together
can make the common European future and
this common European future like in
total petunias sound is a future where
we reach out to each other in order to
build a set of values institutions to
have quality of life a space to live
together with common ideals I believe
that this approach would provide a new
dynamic to this mentor student relation
it would enhance the perspective of
cooperation and collaboration it will
increase the responsibilities of all the
parts in terms of the effects the
membership and integration process have
in citizens daily life what the new
agenda in new enlargement puts the South
East European region in front is a
larger denser and three folded
cooperation collaboration within the
South Eastern European region
collaboration of the region with the EU
collaboration of each country with EU
the first two are explained as a
combination of objectives Southeast
Europe
2020 strategy with Europe 2020 agenda
yet there is still important way to go
in this combination because I think
there is important way to go in original
cooperation and in transforming the
Europe 2020 agenda in concrete steps
that affect the quality of life and JE
democracy in each country so we are not
only in front of the challenge of making
stronger the link between national and
regional level or the challenge of
complementarity in national level with
Europe 2020 we all together or tential
candidate candidate States and member
states face the challenge of addressing
sustainable inclusive integrated Smart
Growth and governance for growth each
included in South East Europe 22 vision
coherently and blend it in with Europe
2020 agenda we all together are
confronted to the challenge of putting
daily democracy citizens quality of life
and improved rule of law at the heart of
a sustainable development and growth
oriented agenda this degree of
cooperations bring to my mind the
approach his work as a crazy and
reflexivity of two French social
scientists Benedict Zimmerman and
Michelle Werner
it reminds me of his work was a a shared
fates and reflectivities as shaping each
other faiths using some elements from
their approach I will say that in the
region we have to find our inter
crossing and particularly how we affect
in good each other we have to find how
we could collaborate in micro level
regionals particular products trade
particular offers but not to the
detriment of the general particularly in
the region we should start from our
divergences among various possible
viewpoints to reach our convergences to
multiply them and
in terms of the above-mentioned three
folded corporation we should be mindful
of both short-term context affection and
the long-term structural condition that
make it possible so we could be able to
manage change and stability at the same
time however changing scale to come back
to an individual country Albania it
seems to me that the result-oriented
corporation mainly highlighted for the
regional corporation should be
particularly mentioned for the
collaboration of EU and particular
countries because as I said we in
Albania have many EU certified laws
prepared with a lot of assistance which
required also a lot of energy and
financial sources but we have as you
must have heard a rampant corruption
which drains lot of energy and financial
sources an endemic political and
administrative corruption that stands as
a huge obstacle before democratic
institution justice sustainable growth
and even before the development of the
educational system in the country an
endemic invasive corruption that is
still there in spite of all the progress
towards EU membership taking into
account that Slovenia Croatia and
Bulgaria have been more successful in
this process could we say that this is a
problem particular to Albanians not
necessarily particular to probably a
very serious systemic problem in Albania
I do believe that our the citizens the
people that corrupt a system I believe
that the system incoherent with the
needs and aspirations that built it
corrupts the people the system in which
an Albanian public official works is far
from being democratic or responding to
citizens need thus it can be corrupted
for whatever individual involved in such
process while in cases where where we do
not have such corruption let's mention
the French or German system it is almost
impossible to use the Mystery Machine
for personal and/or individual benefit
the modern democratic
adversative mechanism I refer to
obviously requires law regulations
technology but also and mainly it
requires now political will I believe
that the best way to fight and prevent
corruption in short term is the
modernization of the state institutions
you will say to me now easier said than
done yes I would say where there is will
there is way here is an example the
first foreign guest with institutional
power to visit my office as mayor of
Tiana was Crick Portman at a time World
Bank country director this constituted
an extraordinary visit because his
predecessors but also him had not
previously been in the municipality of
Tirana actually world bank's country
office staff had been to my office
several times but they kept on noting
the problems we reported and I kept on
talking with them about Albanian history
art literature even Albanian culinary
art or climate unless they were willing
to discuss a concrete project my refusal
to talk serious subjects unless it was a
project was reported to the main office
in Washington referring to the strange
mayor and his free chat formula this had
taken the attention of the country
director who decided to visit the
strange mayor with great modesty as
every wise man Crick Portman and
impressive personality
set in the guest corner of the office
and said to me would you like anything
to drink tea coffee still water
sparkling water you are quick Portman he
said to me World Bank country director
and I am a drama he said for himself the
mayor of Tirana for whom the World Bank
has done nothing I congratulate him for
the good shot and explained that I was
ready to go beyond the free chat formula
with the condition of not receiving the
habitual answer what an interesting
project but unfortunately it does not
sweet to our problems
it was nice to meet you he accepted and
on my invitation we both went to a small
window at the waiting lounge of my
office siting the back part of his body
there were two barracks constructed
during the Kosovo war virus services on
the city hall were offered from these
barracks people waited in long queue to
obtain various certifications permits
informations or submit a complaint the
employees inside the barrack responding
to the citizens from the small windows
would process or not these requests
would respond or not to the complaint
without having anyone checking their
responsibility or the efficacy of the
service more ever in order to deal with
the endless queue and have their
requests processed or to obtain whatever
permit of certification required
citizens went to the back door of the
barrack bribed one of the employees
inside and the job was done actually we
saw with our eyes someone knocking into
the back door and offering the penalty
to have a service provided by a law
preventing all this from going on was
not about catching the corrupted
employees on the act dismissing them and
replacing them with others preventing
all this passed through providing to
those employees decent working
conditions to the city dwellers a decent
waiting lounge a computerized system
registering requests a system that
provided monitoring throughout the
process fighting and preventing
corruption passed through transformation
of space regulations and procedures that
would reshape the relation of a city
dweller with a City Hall what I asked
from director was the financing of such
space for the City Hall thought not only
we discussed a larger project that
through reshaping its space would
reshape the whole function in the
municipality a functioning henceforth
characterized not by bribe long queues
and exhausting ineffective service
but by Transparency professionalism
self-respect and respect to citizens the
waiting room became a first in its type
in Albanian administration Gianna news
party became the first European public
institution in the country related to
the citizens the project a success story
for the World Bank and the beginning of
a long successful collaboration between
the city hall and the World Bank so said
and done though it requires will
political will the same will need to
transform the process of integration to
the European Union to a chain of results
visible in the daily life of each of our
countries in the Balkans will to
transform Europe to what is supposed to
be since the Marshall Plan and
Washington agreements and the European
Union since the Rome Agreement then
since master it and late Lisbon a space
of prosperity a place with natural not
imposed borders and not in vain I
mentioned the Marshall Plan and the
Washington agreement because this
determination to integration to the
European Union is not about Eurocentrism
about worrying only for the region or
ourselves while we live in a deeply
interconnected world where it is
discussed about global citizenship
connected histories interrelated faiths
know the determination to integration
and to Albania like Europe that the
nourishing of an imaginary of Europe
united Europe is about contributing to
the success of a brilliant international
project the European Union that would
contribute to the prosperity of millions
and to a better world
this project is brilliant due to the
values in which it is based the harsh
experience on which it was built and
which it should avoid forever due to the
social cultural and political
sensitivities it endorses and the
Democratic institutional framework it
aims to build it is brilliant because it
defies the nation not the nation as an
entity of
hope and liberation buzzes entity of
prejudicing and discrimination with the
agreement between serbian crossover
lately our region closes for good a
chapter of conflicts while it opens for
good a new chapter for the Albanians
Kosovars Montenegrin Serbians
Macedonians boston's this must be a
start of acting and enacting candidacy
acting so not to remain waiting what
kind of legislation Brussels would
propose so we adopted but it does not
matter if we adopted acting to be active
parts even in the formation of this
legislation and acting to transform it
into reality in our countries acting to
be result oriented in a process of
fulfilling the criteria of membership
enacting means not expecting how
Brussels proposed to combine Southeast
Europe 2020 strategy with Europe 2020
agenda or leave this to some inter
ministerial meetings but including
larger popular debate on this including
the civil society in such debate
including universities be more and more
inclusive and more and more
results-oriented in terms of enacting I
think that Croatia and Slovenia
constitutes important examples to the
other countries of the region they have
been distinctively successful in the U
membership process and could be crucial
guidance also in engineering and
effective regional cooperation this
moment of a new agenda moment when many
things have been done but much remains
still to be done and innovation is
needed can be grasped as a moment of
change change in our approach change in
our way of acting change in our way of
cooperating so let's me go back to the
begging but of European Union and that
of Albania in its way to the European
Union and say as the song goes in siena
together with awareness that the current
future of next generation Europe is
building memory countries as much as in
candidate countries as much as in
potential
candidates unite unite Europe and yes
easier said than done
though as we saw it just takes will and
with such will it can be done thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Prime Minister Thank You Prime
Minister for that honest and
inspirational speech especially
appreciate the address the willingness
to address corruption and the appeal to
regional interests we have perhaps a
dozen minutes for questions I would ask
you to ask one question please don't say
I have three questions for you to serve
so you have a question thank you and
we're also interested in his response
not in your political opinion so I'd ask
you to ask a question and not tell us
about your political opinions with that
warning
let us begin I will look and see if I
can see about six people and commit
their hands to memory and then go around
the room we'll see how long that takes
good morning to everybody uh Maria
Marsol Bree my name is Aubrey on bingo
Shibuya I come from Albania boy email
Mesmer's work world view high school my
high school name is world view high
school my principal is dr. Nicols
medidas o te amo
good afternoon mr. ama OS currency emoji
Amparo Yosh it's a big pleasure that I'm
in front of you
PJ emerged and my question is tillers
Chile's planning in the 2008 prevent the
Puna the talks are what is your plan for
jobs and employments yeah
thank you very much you are merciless
first question toughest question I'll
try to be short we have a big problem in
front of us because our sources of
growth that so far has been instrumental
for our economy are practically not
anymore there as such remittances from
immigrants have fallen down dramatically
and just consider that they were around
15% of our GDP the construction boom is
over so in general the economic model of
these years is somehow exhausted
although was a model based in a jobless
growth so our challenge is on one hand
to find new sources of growth and on the
other hand to have a growth based on
creating new jobs and for sure this is
something the country can afford because
we have importance potentials and we can
generate new resources I would mention
very
briefly our potential in hydro we are
the second richest country in Europe for
water resources our potential in tourism
in rural development and also in oil and
mining and last but not least our
potential in developing a much larger
network of manufacturing which has shown
to be pretty successful so far but which
can grow and create new jobs from Mike -
Mike so we take the next question from
the person who is standing in the front
there thank you thank you
good morning mr. prime minister I
believe you voted and directed your
party to vote for the president of the
Albanian Parliament or chair of the
Albanian Parliament the same man that
you said two years ago was the most
corrupt man in Albania the same man you
led a protest against where four people
got killed
if corruption is something that you're
battling how can you guarantee no
corruption in a country where in fact
you are ensuring it with your own votes
and your own directives first of all we
created coalition named lines for Europe
for Albanian for European Albania which
got 1 million votes so this is the best
answer to a question given by the people
people decided to vote for this
coalition in the largest numbers ever
and on the other hand my answer for you
is very simple
I mentioned it also in my speech it's
not people corrupting systems it's about
systems grabbing people so fighting
against corruption for us in Albania is
modernizing modernizing modernizing it's
making the system
immune from personal agenda and this is
a way to make hi my name is Adam Halbert
I study anthropology and archaeology my
question is this it's a little bit
different than it is I'm how has being
an artist made you a better leader how
has being an artist made you a better
leader I don't know if you've made me a
better leader but I am here because of
the contest I think my history is not
any particular in the context of former
communist empire in a moment of change
many artists and intellectuals got in
the scene as leaders or as part of
entire regime movements many of them
continued to do politics many of them
failed I hope it's not my case
we'll see
you say the crib minister welcome Prime
Minister didn't gosh Columbia CPA
alumnus because I'm originally from the
region you you could guess that I spent
a lot of my leisure time in Albania a
very beautiful I'm from neighboring
Kosovo and just this summer I was less
than a month ago I wasn't there me one
of the most beautiful places in Albania
and and every time I try to tell my
American and foreign friends about
visiting I always hope that the
infrastructure just a little better you
know because I'm sort of I'm willing to
be like you know I'll go I'll enjoy it
because I'm sort of it's nearby for me
but what what is your goal in terms of
improving infrastructure so more people
can have it easier to see what I'll
being has to offer tourism wise we have
hard time to go miss people to come
because Albania is not a place to go but
it's a place to always go back so once
they come then they always want to go
back to come back so the the challenge
is how to make them come first time and
first time is not infrastructure that is
in their mind is this image of the
country which is quite dark and which
has been legitimately but also not let
me create it for for people all over the
world so of course we need to improve
infrastructure but the most important
thing to be improved is our image abroad
and in that respect I am really grateful
to you and to everyone here coming from
Albania because you are the most
wonderful assets for us to improve our
image and I want very much to open a new
chapter in the relations between the
country and the government with you with
the well-educated or on the way of being
well educated Albanians abroad in the
States or in Europe and we'll have soon
some initiatives in trying to reach out
to you
and to work together for improving the
image of our country and for making
Albania easier destination because one
thing is sure once they come then they
come back easily so our effort should be
to make them then come back first time
thank you I want to congratulate you for
your elections that win and thank you
for you are here I want to thank mr.
David Phillips and Columbia University
for organizing such things my name is
sali bellotti
i was born in albanian samaria region in
greece I am one of survivors of genocide
of Greece against Albanians in 1994 I
was very glad with your program in
election that you are out there that
chance question will be resolved I am
curious to know how we resolved that is
one law in Greece that Albania and
Greece are still in war and the second
is that were both members of the NATO
and we had another treaty friendship
yeah please you won't answer or you want
to have a speech answer thank you okay
so the answer is in our program and
thank you for having read it and for
appreciating it we're the first
political party ever in Albania to put
it straight forward in our program and
this will take a process it's not
something that can be solved nor by
fueling the fire of nationalism which
would be a disaster either by stepping
back so we need to engage in dialogue
and we
to engage in a process in full respect
of international agreements and
international laws so and this is Seoul
I'm very confident my name is Anna Katz
I'm a Barnard alum
you've talked a lot about changing the
political landscape in Albania but
you've also done a lot to change the
physical topography in the country
specifically with your master plan your
redevelopment of the master plan for
Tirana what do you perceive as the rules
of urbanism and architecture in
reimagining post-communist Albania and
how would you like to see it Rana
develop as a city thank you very much
for the question because if that is one
of the most most sensitive points in my
vision of the country I strongly believe
that our country needs total reshape in
terms of physical organization and in
terms of physical protection in terms of
sustainable development
- not developed further to not develop
further as we did in all these years by
destroying our resources because for
sure Albanians live better today than 20
years ago but Albania physically is not
in better shape
we have lost lots of agricultural land
we have lost a lot of forests a lot of
sustainability in all parts of the
country and in all layers so we need to
engage in a huge urban development plan
and
for and we'll do it because it's very
much linked with the economy is very
much linked with the well-being of our
communities and is very much linked with
the next generation so thank you
hi miss prime Esther and I mean Chinese
of C student and you know this very
special relationship in China and our
pain yeah once in history and now I just
have sha question there is how do you
come on present sino albania
relationship and what kind of
constructive role do you think china can
play in turn off building up at Patsy
Europe thank you
yeah we had a very special relationship
to be to be truthful and I was very
surprised when I went in Beijing some
years ago and we went in a in a place
where you could you could make shirts
and being four or six XL I don't know
how big an I need this and so we went in
a place where they were doing it in a
quite fast and cheap way and I was
surprised that once the ladies there
knew that we were coming from Albania
they started to sing of being sung so it
was a time through the time but now it's
a new time and it's different iran's
thanks God we are not nostalgic of that
time in terms of dictatorship and all
this but for sure China is very
important partner for sure we are very
much willing to increase the cooperation
with China and to welcome more
investments from China and we are having
some very positive developments in that
respect
thank you very much with that I would
like to thank you and give you a few
moments if you wish to comment further
or as you wish
thank you I started by saying you it was
it's one of my very first if not the
first exercise to have a speech as Prime
Minister in front of an audience
and believe me it's not easy because
it's a completely different position and
language should be a bit different it's
like this famous joke someone was
talking about his camel and saying I
have a camel it's the best in the world
it works
miles and doesn't ask anything nor to
drink nor to eat it eats once a week and
it's enough it drinks one every three
day and somebody listening said can i
buy your camel and I said of course
there is a price for everything so if
you want to buy it just propose me the
right price and then the guy buys it
with a very important price and a few
days later he calls balances but what
was all this propaganda this camera is
broken it's asking me three times a day
to drink water doesn't want to walk more
than a mile and then rest it's sleeping
health what is this this is impossible
how you could sell me and we all said
don't speak evil about your camel
because you'll not be able to sell him
so it's a bit like government in
opposition now and I'm very thankful for
your at for your patience and I hope it
was not just out of being very
well-educated but also something was
interesting in my speech and I very much
hope that if my grandmother will be here
shields not be disappointed because as
she told me when I was a kid
in every every time that I was I was
disappointed with something my son
don't worry sometimes wouldn't be wrong
sometimes you can make mistakes we stay
there for people sometimes you can
disappoint people it's okay
the only thing you should really worry
it's to please don't be boring so I hope
I was not boring
thank you
[Applause]